As far as the three other system qualities in
an object oriented architectural style, performance has problems because of
the many small objects linked to multiple context switches.
And delegation, okay,
whereby one object may refer to others to provide its functionality,
this can increase indirection, which can reduce responsiveness of the system.
With respect to reliability, decentralized control in
object oriented system reduces opportunity for oversight.
But encapsulation can reduce vulnerability to undin, unintended interactions.
For safety, the correspondence between the real-world entities which the system
is is modeling, and the objects that the programmer has
developed can improve the intentionality of the system and
accountability, thereby enhancing the safety of the system.